Next up, get your Instagram feed fired up
because we've got an account that you must follow.
UNILAD reports that this photographer
captures incredible freeze frames of dogs, catching treats.
(audience aws)
Okay, the photographer is Christian Vieler
and he's been taking
these action shots for years.
Oh my God!
And I gotta tell you
this is exactly what I look like when my Postmates arrive.
(Ross laughs)
(Drew laughs)
That's what I would look like
at the barbecue place, eating the ribs.
Totally.
Absolutely.
With the ex-boyfriend who's got a bloated sense of self
and think that's all about him.
This is so cute.
(Drew chuckles)
But imagine how many outtakes he has.
'Cause have you ever tried to take a picture
of your dogs for like a Christmas card or something
and it's just impossible.
Yeah, it's me with the kids.
I'm taking pictures of us all the time
and it's like maybe one a year,
do I get that's like semi passable.
Yeah, here's a tip.
If you're taking a picture of your dog,
get a squeaky toy and squeak it and like.
Oh, that's cute.
They look, yeah.
Well maybe you should follow Christian Vieler
and throw treats.
I mean those pictures are just joy.
Yeah, aw (laughs).
And this is
an Instagram account
that's gonna truly boost my life.
Uh huh.
I mean, that's a lot of what Instagram is about
is to give you some information,
show you beautiful art, news, information
but just come across something that just makes you smile.
And this one does it for me.
Well, yeah.
(audience cheers)
I don't follow Christian yet, but you know what?
I'm gonna throw you a bone.
I'm gonna follow you.
Yeah.
Little pun.
All right, hey, I love this next story.
It comes all the way from Poland.
Apartment Therapy reports a group there
is trying to fight loneliness
with something called Happy to Chat benches.
Oh.
These benches they're special.
And they've been installed in public parks.
They encourage a connection between strangers.
Instructions are printed right there on the bench.
It says, "Sit here,
if you don't mind stopping to say hello."
Now, it's like your Forest Gump fantasy.
If you are feeling a little lonely
and you wanna sit down
and just meet a stranger,
find somebody else,
get a glimpse, a window into somebody else's life.
This is the bench for you.
And I love things that are designated areas to meet people.
It's why I love singles nights at bars
because it's like, "Go here.
Yep.
Everyone's in the mood to meet somebody."
Well, on this bench,
You can meet your next best friend.
I love this, I really do.
I lived on my own in my first apartment when I was 14
and I wasn't able to drive.
And I lived in Los Angeles, which is not a walking city.
And sometimes I would take the bus
and I had just read this book called Desiderata.
And it had this caption in it that said,
"Listen to people, for they have their stories too."
And when I read that,
I fell so in love with it.
It changed my life and I was riding the bus a lot.
So a bus bench was a great place for me
to hear people's stories and strike up conversation.
That's so cute.
And you know what, I feel like you do that
on this show every day, is we meet people.
We find their stories
and we're inspired by them every single day.
And I would encourage anybody out there
in any city where you're watching this,
put a bench like this in your park
and just see what happens.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
It's very Notting Hill, by the way.
Oh my God.
Hello.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪